we have spent many videos talking about
the three branches of government in the
United States the legislative branch
which passes the budgets and makes laws
the executive branch which runs the
government and the judicial branch that
determines whether things that are
happening are constitutional or not and
can interpret the laws and when we talk
about these separate powers and we talk
about the checks and balances they have
on each other the thing that you might
not have thought about until this point
is how many employees each of them have
and so I encourage you to pause this
video and just make a guess how many
employees do you think each of these
branches have or more importantly how
many employees which one which of these
do you think is the biggest well to the
answer your question the great majority
of federal employees are within the
executive branch and we're talking about
a very large number of people if you
don't include soldiers we are still
talking about more than 2.5 million
people under the executive branch if you
include the soldiers then we're starting
to approach closer to four million
people under the executive branch and so
what you see on this org chart is that
most of it sits under the executive and
that's because the executive branch is
charged with running the government and
so you have the familiar roles the
president the vice-president the
executive office of the president then
you have the various cabinet departments
right over here and I could move to the
left and the right so you can see them
things like the Department of
Agriculture Department of Interior
Department of Commerce Department of
Justice Department of Defense Education
State on and on and on and on and then
within each of these departments they
can be quite quite large you could be
talking about thousands or in some cases
even tens of thousands of employees but
it's not just about those departments if
we go further down in this diagram right
over here you see independent
establishments and government
corporations that are under the
executive branch things like the United
States Postal Service the Peace Corps
you have the Federal Reserve System
these are all under
the executive branch and when you take
all of these things in total together
it's known as the federal bureaucracy
now the word bureaucracy might conjure
up some images for you you might imagine
going to some type of a government
office and trying to apply for something
and then having to fill out a bunch of
paperwork or sit in line and then wait
for something and so sometimes it gets a
bad name even the word bureaucratic
tends to mean something that is a lot of
process and not necessarily something
that moves quickly or moves efficiently
but it's worth noting that even though a
lot of people we'd like to pick on the
bureaucracy and it is worth debating on
how efficient government is at certain
things we do need some form of a
bureaucracy without a government
bureaucracy you would not have experts
checking on whether your food is safe
checking on which drugs actually work
you would not have thoughtful people who
are thinking about how do we run our
military how do we determine how we
engage with other countries so we do
need a federal bureaucracy these are the
folks that are doing things like writing
and enforcing regulations they're
issuing fines if you have bad actors it
may be a corporation that is polluting
where they're not supposed to now where
do these people come from well a lot of
times the heads of these various
departments say the Secretary of Defense
who's at the top of the Department of
Defense or the Secretary of State they
are political appointees they are
pointed by the President and confirmed
by the Senate we talk about that in
other videos but the great majority of
the bureaucracy does not come from what
is known as political patronage
political patronage is hey you really
helped me with my campaign and I think
you're a pretty decent person I'm gonna
give you a plum job at the top of the
bureaucracy and even the word plum job
you should maybe take it with a grain of
salt because some of these jobs do
require a lot of responsibility but the
great majority of the bureaucracy is not
from political patronage but it's
actually merit-based that these are
folks they might take the civil service
exam they might have a graduate degrees
in something that's relevant let's say
if they're working in the Food and Drug
Administration they might know a little
about chemistry or biology and will
often and no organization is perfect
oftentimes people get promoted for the
wrong reason but for the most part
they're going to be promoted based on
merit so it's completely reasonable for
us to debate how large this bureaucracy
should be and for sure our federal
bureaucracy is sometimes inefficient but
we do need it and we're talking about
millions of people many of whom are
experts in their field who are really
just trying to help us run our
government